继GPU、存储、光模块之后
AI产业链上又一个爆点出现了
那就是 CPU
这个季度
CPU“三巨头”集体交出了炸裂财报
曾经被视为“AI弃子”的英特尔
逆风翻盘
收入、毛利率、每股收益
均大幅度地超过指引上限
受AI驱动的数据中心业务同比大涨22%
财报发布次日 英特尔股价暴涨24%
创下近40年来最大的单日涨幅
而过去一个月
英特尔的股价已经翻了一倍多
AMD和Arm的表现也非常惊人
AMD整体营收首次突破100亿美元
其中数据中心业务单季收入
达到58亿美元 同比暴涨57%
公司直接把2030年的
服务器CPU市场规模预测
从600亿美元上调了一倍到1200亿美元
而Arm不仅版权收入收到手软
现金流起飞
首款专为AI数据中心打造的Arm AGI CPU
更是已经被排队预定
锁定需求超过20亿美元
预计未来5年
还会将Arm的云AI市场空间扩大40倍
三家CPU巨头的业绩和指引集体暴涨
说明AI算力需求已经开始
从GPU进一步蔓延到了整个计算系统
在超强的需求之下
CPU目前也陷入了全面短缺
产品价格不断走高
甚至连残次品现在也在被排队抢购
那么CPU为什么会突然从“AI配角”
开始重新回归到“基础设施核心”
CPU短缺到底是怎么回事
这样的短缺潮又会持续多久呢
Hello 大家好
欢迎收看《硅谷101》 我是陈茜
上次我们聊完存储芯片的“超级周期”
今天这期内容我们就来看看CPU短缺
从2025年第四季度开始
服务器CPU的平均售价已经涨了将近30%
这在高度成熟的CPU市场极为罕见
伴随而来的是供货紧缺
交付周期已从过去的1到2周
普遍拉长到了8到12周
部分型号甚至要等六个月
如果只是涨价也倒还好
但更可怕的是 在消费端
有供应商开始担心“加价也拿不到货了”
这场短缺的两个原因
第一是Agent爆发
当AI运行的时候 需要CPU来调度工具
处理数据、执行代码、验证结果
编排各种流程等等
GPU则只负责计算
而Agent相比普通的AI来说
会执行多个任务
相当于GPU算的各种东西
都得让CPU来负责整合
随着GPU速度越来越快
很多任务都会堆积到CPU身上
从而拖慢速度
有论文就指出
当Agent运行在高性能GPU平台的时候
来自CPU的延迟高达65%
这就像一家餐厅 GPU负责炒菜
CPU要洗菜、刷碗、装盘、上菜
当GPU炒菜越来越快的时候
出餐速度就会卡在CPU身上
而第二个原因
是大模型上下文窗口越来越长
现在不少模型都纷纷迈入了百万token级别
能够让一次对话记忆更多
这也意味着
KV Cache（键值缓存）急剧膨胀
当显存装不下这些缓存的时候
有些数据就得被卸载到SSD那边去
交给CPU来处理
这又给CPU添了个新活儿
目前数据中心CPU和GPU的配比
已经从1:4或1:8
提升到了1:1或者1:2
也就是需求增长了4倍
这才导致了短缺
可能有人就会问了
既然需求来自于数据中心
那我日常买个电脑应该不影响吧
这其中的原因就和内存一样
存在产能挤压的情况
短缺其实还是在服务器端
就不是在consumer（消费者）这一端
但这个造成的影响在于
所有的CPU企业
在服务器端做CPU可以挣更多的钱
所以他们会把他们的产能
全部尽量地拿去给
server（服务器）端的CPU
把产能从C端抽出来
实际上也对C端CPU的供给会产生影响
那供给端在做什么
目前CPU的产能主要受限于两点
晶圆生产和封装材料
我们先来说一下晶圆生产
众所周知
全球最先进的晶圆代工产能
集中在台积电
除了AMD Intel也有部分CPU
需要交给台积电
但是利润更高的GPU订单
几乎拿到了绝对的优先权
挤占了CPU的产能配比
而且台积电2026年的先进制程产能
早已卖光了
2027年的产能也几乎快没了
至于英特尔 也没好到哪去
虽然英特尔有自己的晶圆厂
并且开始量产18A工艺
但是目前良率低下
而且产能爬坡最快也需要一年的时间
（英特尔18A）它的良率（yield）
现在还上不来
可能是30% 也可能50%
一般从现在这个良率
如果能够提高到80%或者90%
有的时候可能很快 大概一年
有的时候要两三年
而且CPU生产我们还不能光盯着裸片看
承载裸片的ABF载板也非常关键
主流高性能CPU和GPU封装
都离不开ABF载板
而AI芯片不仅面积
扩大到原来的3到8倍
层数和封装复杂度也同步提升
这使得单颗芯片
对ABF的消耗指数级增长
而且别忘了 除了CPU需求增长之外
还有大热的GPU
一直对ABF的产量虎视眈眈
这就导致了关键的原材料
T-Glass玻纤布同样面临缺货
在这样的环境下 各大厂商又在怎么做
AMD是这轮需求爆发中最大的受益者
不过也是最焦虑的受益者
由于AMD第五代EPYC芯片
性能优于英特尔
因此更受服务器市场青睐
但它的生产完全来自于台积电
加上我们前面提到
GPU的需求挤占了CPU的产量配比
因此AMD只能被动等待产量释放
并且提前向台积电锁定产能
我们再来看一下英特尔那边
它们不光加快
提升自家晶圆厂18A制程的良率
还以142亿美元回购了2年前出售的
爱尔兰晶圆厂49%的股份
相比当时的出售价还多了30亿
这样一来 英特尔重新掌握了
该晶圆厂所有的股权
意味着收回了产能控制权
随着CPU需求爆发
市场还加入了新的竞争者
比如说英伟达
虽然早在2021年 英伟达就推出过
基于Arm架构的Grace CPU
但一般都是作为GPU的“配货”
来捆绑售卖
但这次不一样了
今年GTC上 老黄推出了Vera CPU
不仅独立售卖 还号称专为Agent打造
明显就是冲着这波CPU热潮来的
Vera CPU将在今年下半年正式出货
并且已经和Meta、阿里、字节
Cloudflare、CoreWeave等公司宣布合作
更有意思的是
过去只做IP授权的Arm
也亲自下场做CPU了
这款CPU命名为“AGI CPU”
看名字就知道 打的就是AI市场
基于台积电的3纳米工艺
和Neoverse V3内核构建
由Arm与Meta共同开发
所以市场信号就是
CPU正在重新夺回AI市场的地位
而巨头们谁都不想缺席
在我们采访的嘉宾看来
虽然这轮短缺
对英伟达和Arm的CPU是机会
但是增长点有限
只是说存量市场X86太大
所以他们（英伟达和Arm）还是
不会短期地吃到他们（英特尔和AMD）很多份额
那这场短缺还会持续多久呢
有意思的是 行业为了解决短期的缺货
甚至把各种的“残次品”都拿出来卖了
这是一个行业都面临的问题
所以英特尔自己也说了
现在很多边角废料
或者说一些不好的wafer（晶圆）
有瑕疵的芯片 客户也愿意接
即使它可能很快就会烧掉
我相信AMD最终也是走这个方法
客户愿意接受边角料的
有瑕疵的芯片的话
只能通过这个方法来补产能
而要想根本性地解决短缺
主要还是要看两个方面
分别是晶圆厂和原材料
最重要的台积电
已经计划将部分5nm产线转化为3nm
同时还有三个工厂正在建设
台南工厂计划在2027年上半年投产
亚利桑那州工厂为2027年的下半年
熊本工厂则要等到2028年
而英特尔那边 前面的嘉宾提到
要提升到满意的良率 最快也要1年
而ABF的核心材料T-Glass玻纤布
全球90%的产能
都来自于一家日本厂商Nittobo
他们已经宣布
将福岛工厂的产能扩充了3倍
但是最快也需要在2027年才能够产出
最终要看就是Agentic AI起来有多快
如果起来很快的话
那这个短缺的缺口其实会再继续扩大
而不再缩减
所以综合来看 这轮CPU短缺
甚至是整个芯片短缺潮
最快可能也要2027年下半年才会缓解
但这还只是按照目前需求
估计的乐观结果
如果Agent需求继续增长
可能缺口还会继续扩大
从GPU到内存再到CPU
这场由AI应用落地引发的结构性短缺
你认为会持续多久呢
欢迎到评论区一起讨论
以上就是本期视频的全部内容了
你们的留言、点赞和转发
是支持我们《硅谷101》
做好深度科技和商业内容的最佳动力
我是陈茜 那我们下期视频再见了 拜